what are the tools with which we can
talk about the Observer
the subjective view in reality what are
the tools of which we could talk about
rigorously talk about Free Will and
Consciousness what are the tools of
mathematics that allow that I don't
think we have those tools because we
haven't been taught properly so actually
tools are there for instance
um
I think well
here we have to
I have to say my conviction is that
everybody knows
in the heart of hearts everybody knows
that there is that there is something
ineffable there is something
mysterious and in fact you know
somehow immediately I feel that
um you know the impulse to quote
somebody on this because as if as if my
own opinion doesn't occur
there's a long dead expert that has been
Einstein said that he doesn't like how
see look at me I am supposedly like this
smart intelligent person
I am afraid to say it and own it myself
I have to find a confirmation I have to
find an authority who agrees with me and
in fact it's not so difficult to find
because Albert Einstein literally said
the most important thing in life is the
mysterious okay he actually said that
there are some quotes which are
attributed to him which he never said
but this he did I investigated okay so
but more importantly you know
how do you feel about it
um I think that everybody knows
but
in other words he also said Einstein
imagination is more important than
knowledge okay and it's it's playing for
knowledge is always Limited
whereas the imagination Embraces the
entire world giving birth to Evolution
it is uh strictly speaking a real factor
in scientific research he says and he
says I am enough of an artist to follow
my intuition and Imagination as Albert
Einstein again so and I feel the same
way to be honest if I think about my own
mathematical research
it's never linear
it's never like give me more data give
me more data give me more data Boom the
glass is full and then I come up with a
discovery no it's always it always is
always felt as a jump as a leap
and I I have actually been studying
various examples in a history of
mathematics of some fundamental
discoveries like Discovery complex
numbers like square root of negative one
I wonder if a large language model could
actually ever come up with the idea that
square root square root of negative one
is something that is essential or
meaningful because if all the
information that you get
that all the all the knowledge that had
been accumulated up to that point tells
you that you cannot have a square root
of a negative number why because if you
had such a square root
we know that if then we would have to if
you square it you get a negative number
but we know that if you square any real
number positive or negative you will
always get a positive number so
Checkmate you know it's over square root
of negative one doesn't exist yet we
know that these numbers make sense
they're called complex numbers and in
fact quantum mechanics is based on
complex numbers they are in essential
and indispensable for quantum mechanics
could one discover that so to me that
sounds like
I discontinue it in the process of
discovery it's a jump It's a departure
it is like a child who is experimenting
it's like a child who says I'm not
afraid to be an idiot everybody says the
adults are saying square root of
negative number doesn't exist but guess
what I'm going to accept it and I'm
going to play with it and I'm going to
see what happens this is literally how
they were discovered there was an
Italian
mathematician Astro astronomer
astrologer he was he made money
apparently by compiling astrological
sort of readings for uh for the elite
you know of his ERA this is 16th century
everyone does a gambler
all around interesting guy I'm sure we
would have an interesting conversation
with him gerolamo cardano he's all he
also invented the what's called cardan
shaft so which is an essential component
of of a car
we say in Russian
so
so he wrote a book which is called uh
our ass Magna which is like the great
art of algebra and he was writing
solutions for the
cubic and cortic equations
this is something that is familiar
because
it's cool we study Solutions of
quadratic equations equations of degree
two so you have x a x squared plus BX
plus C equals zero and there is a
Formula which solves it using radicals
using square roots
and cardano was trying to find a similar
formula for the cubic and quartic
equations for which which would start
with x cubed or x to the power 4 as
opposed to x squared and in the process
of solving these equations it came up
with square root of a negative number
specifically square root of -17
and he wrote that I have to forego some
mental tortures
to deal with it but I am going to accept
it and see what happens and in fact at
the end of the four at the end of the
calculation
this this this weird numbers got
canceled it kind of canceled out in the
formula appeared square root of negative
17 and it's negation so they kind of
conveniently give the right answer which
is not involve those numbers so he was
like okay
what does it mean mental tortures so you
see from the point of view
over of the of the thinking mind
it is something almost unbearable it's
almost I feel that a long large language
more the computer running a large
language model trying to do that would
just explode and yet a human
mathematician was able to find the
courage and inspiration to say you know
what what is wrong why why are we so
adamant that these things don't exist
that's just our past knowledge based on
what our past knowledge is and knowledge
is limited what if we make the next step
today for us mathematicians context
numbers that we call them are not at all
mysterious the idea is simply that
you plot real numbers that is to say all
the whole numbers like 0 1 and so on to
and so on right all fractions like one
half or three halves or four over three
but then also numbers like square root
of two or Pi we plot them as points on
the real line so we draw this is a this
is one of the kind of perennial Concepts
even in a in our very poor math
curriculum at school but now imagine
that instead of one line you have a pla
you have a one axis you have a second
axis
and so you numbers now have two chords
in it X and Y and you associate to this
point with coordinates X and Y
the number X which is a real number plus
y times square root of negative one this
is a graphical geometrical
representation of complex numbers which
is not mysterious at all now it took
another two or three hundred years for
mathematicians to figure that out but
initially it looked like a completely
crazy idea you know
so all it is all a complex number is
it's just the next question
the real part and the imaginary part
it's just an expansion of your view of
the mathematical world the fact that you
can actually multi you can add them up
by adding um together the real parts and
imagining parts that's easy but there is
also formula for the product for the
multiplication which uses the fact that
square root of minus 1 squared is minus
one
and the amazing thing is that that that
product that multiplication satisfies
the same rules the same properties that
are usual operation of multiplication
for real numbers for instance there is
an inverse for every non-zero number
that you can find like number five has
an inverse one over five
but uh one plus I also has an inverse
for instance you know that was always
there in the mathematical universe but
we humans didn't know it and here comes
along this guy who engages in the matter
of torture who takes a leap off the
cliff of comfort of like mathematical
established knowledge establish
knowledge right and now obviously for
each each um sort of
fruitful leap like that they're probably
were thousands of like things which went
nowhere I'm not saying that every Leap
you know it's like it's a it's a it's an
open shooting game yeah because for
example you can try to do the same with
three-dimensional space so you have
coordinates x y and z
and you can say oh uh if there's one
dimensional we have a Bonafide numerical
system called real numbers
if it's two-dimensional which is like
you know geometrically it's just like
the stable top extended to Infinity in
all directions
these are complex numbers and we can
Define addition and multiplication and
they will satisfy the same properties as
real numbers that we're used to what
about three-dimensional space is it
possible to also Define some operation
of addition and multiplication on it so
that these operations would satisfy the
properties that we're used to and the
answer is no you can Define addition but
you can't Define multiplication for
which there would be an inverse for
instance
so there is something special about the
the plane the two-dimensional case and
by the way uh next question would be
what about four-dimensional in a
four-dimensional space you again you can
and you get what's called quaternions
discovered by an Irish mathematician
Hamilton in the 19th century
and then in in the eight dimensional
there is something similar called
octonians and that's about it so how
interesting these structures exist in
dimension one two four and eight
which are all powers of two
Square this four two to the third power
is eight that's one of the bigger
mysteries in mathematics why it is so
so here's a hint that's a hint of
what's missing in our on our high school
curriculum you know the kind of kind of
fascinating the Mysteries yes the
appreciation of the mysterious but so in
other words yes we resolved with this
one mystery that we understood that
square root of negative one
is real is Meaningful we build a theory
to service those now to to describe
those numbers
did we find The Theory of Everything no
because we then invited other Mysteries
because we we push the we pull the whale
so to speak or we push the frontier and
then new things come get illuminated
which we couldn't see before that's how
I see the process of discovering
mathematics it's an endless Limitless
Pursuit